welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
legend of Kora full series recap in the
last air bender Ang and team Avatar
defeated the fire lord and saved the
world on the burn section of the earth
Kingdom they built Republic City where
people of all Nations could live
together in peace Ang lived a long happy
life but eventually the Avatar cycle of
reincarnation continued into cor she's a
real physical busting fists blazing kind
of Avatar she spent her life so far at
her home in the southern water tribe
training with the members of the White
Lotus including Katara who must be real
old now she's already mastered three of
the four elements the only one left is
air but who's going to teach her air
bending a was the last air bender
luckily a got an airbending kid it's
tenzen who's already got three young
airbending kids of his own he takes cor
with him back to Republic City a shiny
Beacon of modern times yet Technology's
progressed very quickly since the last
air bender cor immediately starts
fighting some local gangs but the city
doesn't need her help they've got a
highly trained police force of metal
Benders yeah our girl Toff from the last
air bender after she invented metal
bending founded the Republic City police
force current chief is tof's daughter
Lind Fong and like her mother she's kind
of grumpy on air Temple Island cor is
beginning her air banding training but
she's not really the meditating type the
air banding philosophy of don't attack
evade is not really her style what is
her style is the wildly popular Pro
bending League yeah they've turned
bending into an organized sport she
befriends Earth Bender Bolin who's the
real nice funny guy type he's on the
fire ferrets named after his animal
companion Pabu his brother's a fire
bender named Mako who much like Zuko is
a real serious angsty boy type
conveniently they just lost their water
bender so Ka joins the team and
organized Sports turns out to be the
perfect way for her to understand the
concepts of air bending but there's a
new danger growing in Republic City a
group called The equalists non-benders
Who are sick of being oppressed by the
bending Elite they're led by their super
cool masked leader Aman and somehow he
has the ability just like G did to Fire
Lord oai to take people's bending away
permanently I mean while the fire
ferrets have won their way into the
championship tournament Unfortunately
they don't have enough money to pay the
entrance fee but that changes when Mako
gets hit by a scooter driven by an
absolute knockout assami she's a huge
Pro bending fan and conveniently Super
Rich her father Hiroshi sat is one of
the biggest industrialists in the city
and agrees to sponsor the fire fets the
team is doing great and tilor confesses
her crush on Mako but Mako just started
dating aami awkward but Bolin has a
crush on Kora and she agrees to go out
with him which makes Mako jealous and he
confesses he likes Kora and they kiss
right when Bolin sees it's a mess and it
ruins their team chemistry eventually
they agree this love Square thing is
dumb let's all just be friends now cor
doesn't like Asami at first she's
jealous about Mako and think she's just
a rich girl but actually asami's a
huge badass who likes extreme sports and
soon she and Kora are BFFs but turns out
asami's father is working for the
equalists yes a bender killed his wife
and it turned him into a villain he's
built these epic robots designed to take
down Benders and they made out of
platinum so metal Benders can't bend him
he's like aami join me on the dark side
but she's like no thanks pops I'm going
to be a good guy so she and the Gang
make it their mission to take down the
equalists and they formed the new team
Avatar they're not riding around on a
fluffy animal though they got a sweet
sports car and a super cool steampunk
Vibe councilman tarlock is also
committed to fighting him on but he's
clearly just using this to gain power
for himself pretty soon core finds out
he's a villain but not just any villain
he's a bloodbender yes the terrifying
Technique we learned about in the last
air bender where you bend the water in a
person's body to control them he locks
Cor in his basement where she finally
succeeds at meditating and meets a
grownup Ang oh he got hot he was working
with police chief adult Toff and
councilman adult Saka to take down a
notorious gangster who turns out is a
prodigy bloodbender can do it not during
the full moon and without even moving
Ang eventually goes Avatar State and
takes his bending away turns out
councilman tarlock is his son back for
Revenge but you know who hates all
Benders Aman and somehow blood bending
doesn't affect him oh he takes this
guy's bending away one villain down but
Aman's the bigger threat with asami's
Father's help he's got an army taking
over the city but Republic City's got an
army of their own led by General iro
Zuko's grandson unfortunately asami's
father has just invented airplanes and
oh wipes out their whole Fleet so cor
and Mako use a stealth approach where
they find a locked up tarlock who
explains that Aman is his brother yeah
their father escaped and started a new
life where he had two sons and tried to
teach them the art of bloodbending to
come back and get revenge Aman
especially got very good at it and found
a way through bloodbending to take
people's bending away and now he's got
Kora oh no it's happening yes he's
taking away the avatar T's bending but
wait what's this an airbending Punch
Yeah she had never air bended before so
I guess he couldn't take it away and
with that boom blast him out the window
am mon exposed as water bender and loses
all his followers so he's got a piece
out of there he grabs his brother with a
speedboat and it's like yes brother
we'll come back together and conquer the
city later but tarlock realizes now he
and his brother are the bad guys and so
what's this oh a brother murder suicide
heavy cor's bending though seems to be
permanently gone until she meets a doang
he's like what's up girl me and all your
past lives are here to help unlocks your
bending and yeah Avatar is back in
Action she and Mako start making out and
that's the end of book one in book two
Spirits cor goes home to the southern
water tribe for the annual Spirits
Festival Unilock the chief of the
northern water tribe comes too that is
kora's father's brother and they don't
like each other unok brings his twin
kids with them Esa and desna and bolin's
got a huge crush on whichever WS the
girl Bolin may have bitten off more than
he can chew here he spends the season
trying to dump her but she does not let
him meanwhile Unilock is a real party
pooper he's like this fun Festival
disgraces the spirits he may be right
though because that night a dark Spirit
attacks and Only unok Knows the way to
like disperse it he's like Avatar I need
your help to restore balance we've got
to go down to the southern Spirit portal
where you can use your avatar powers to
Boom reopen it uh so the day is saved
but the next day Uno's whole Army
arrives and occupies the southern water
tribe he's like trust me I'm a good guy
but it's soon apparent he's not
meanwhile Asami is running her father's
company and has a meeting with another
wealthy industrialist and the best
character on the show it's veric he is a
wacky insane genius basically Tony Stark
on steroids he's never far from his
assistant Julie and has this catchphrase
Julie do the thing inum Avatar escape on
his yacht back to Republic City where
they try to convince the president to
help but he's like hey I can't intervene
in internal water tribe Affairs Mako
actually takes the president's side he's
become a republic city cop and chooses
his duty over Kora so oh she dumps his
ass she's going back down to fight
Unilock herself but oh a giant dark
Spirit comes and eats her veric takes
Bolin under his wing he's making
propaganda films about The Water Tribe
Civil War and casts Bolin as the lead
about one day after Kora leaves M and
Asami get back together mako's
investigating a bombing and finds out
that the pyrotechnics in the movie is
the same remote detonator that veric
invented yes veric is the bad guy but he
can't prove it veric has him framed and
arrested K wakes up on an island with
amnesia and has a spirit Vision Quest to
learn about the first avatar Wan in
ancient times Humanity lived on giant
lion turtles who would give them the
power of bending temporarily to defend
themselves against the spirits one
eventually befriended the spirits and
when he saw these giant kite ones
fighting decided to break it up but oo
that was the evil Batu and now he's let
it escape the good spirits robas like
hey I need your help see normally humans
could only have one type of bending but
if I give you some of my power you can
have multiple at a time so want traveled
around to the lion turtles got all the
bending and mastered all the elements so
on the day of harmonic convergence Juan
and raava came to face vatu and with
their powers combined Avatar State
managed to seal him away for good and
they closed the portals to the spirit
world so vatu could never Escape so thus
began the Legacy of the Avatar charged
with keeping balance in the world and
it's raava's spirit that passes on and
reincarnates him when he dies tenzen
meanwhile has been on vacation with his
family including his siblings yeah
angara had two other kids he's the only
air bender though his sister Kai is a
water bender and his brother Boomie is
not a bender but he is insane and
hilarious eventually cor comes back with
the bad news that Uno's going to release
the evil spirit and take over the world
or whatever tends and tries to help cor
meditate into the spirit world but it's
actually his oldest daughter janora who
has the natural connection to the
spirits and who does Kora meet in the
spirit world but Uncle iro apparently
near the end of his life he decided to
abandon his body and come to the spirit
world for permanent retirement and in
true Uncle IO fashion he gives cor some
good tea and good advice the mission's a
huge failure though because janor gets
captured and unok forces Kora to open
the other Spirit portal back in Republic
City balin's a full-on movie star now
and the fictional Unilock is carrying
out his master plan while the real Uno's
kidnapping the president while nuck tuck
Saves the Day on screen Bolin Saves the
Day in real life but turns out they
weren't sent by Unilock they were sent
by veric oh the jigs up baric points out
though that he's not really a bad guy
his whole plot to capture the president
and blame it on unlock was just to get
Republic City to join the war if
anything he's the good guy cor comes
back excited to see her boyfriend moo
yeah she's got just enough Amnesia she
doesn't remember that they broke up and
the love triangle is back on anyway team
avatars go into the North Pole to stop
hok and long story short they get to the
spirit world just too late it's harmonic
convergence and vatu is released from
his prison cor goes Avatar State and
fights this giant kite but this time
vat's got his own human champion and
unlock becomes the dark Avatar they have
an Avatar Fight Unilock doesn't have all
the elements by the way just water but
he does have a huge power up and is able
to pull raava out of Gora he starts
bashing raava directly which erases
kora's past lives until bam rava
destroyed and the Avatar cycle ended
then he turns into a giant spirit
Monster and attacks Republic City now
Republic city is not defenseless it's
got a strong modern Army led by General
iro but they weren't prepared for giant
spirit Monster and unlock wipes out his
whole Fleet then Kora meditates in a
tree and becomes a giant Spirit of
herself and they have a huge Kaiju fight
in the harbor we're in full anime mode
now I have no idea what's happening but
in the end cor is able to save a
fragment of the spirit of Raba and
Destroy Unilock and the avatars back in
business but the memory of all those
past lives were permanently erased so
that's kind of a bummer cor is going to
resal the spirit portals but she's like
wait a second maybe I should leave them
open and humans and Spirits can live
together in harmony TZ and your wise
what do you think and he's like cor I'm
going to be honest with with you I have
no idea what's going on I'm just
sticking around cuz I heard season 3 is
pretty cool so now it's book three
change where Spirits have reinhabited
the world which is nice except that
sometimes they do it in the middle of
the city but there's an unexpected side
effect Uncle Boomie is now an airbender
what and it's not just him a bunch of
random people have suddenly developed
air bending opening the spirit portals
is bringing balance back to the world so
the gang's going to fly around the world
finding air Benders on aami's awesome
new blimp by the way cor finally
remembered that she and Mako broke up
and they agree it's best if we're just
friends mako's very awkward for a bit
around both cor and Assam but this just
brings the girls closer together now
tenzen is very excited to rebuild the AR
noad Nation but turns out most people
are not cut out to be monks they find
one promising recruit though a young
orphan named Kai who starts out as a bit
of a thief and a con artist but
eventually becomes part of the family
but now in a secret prison on top of a
mountain is zah here he was so dangerous
he was locked up here without even being
a bender and now he has air bending so
he bust out of there no problem he
travels to a wooden prison in the middle
of the ocean and tosses some rocks to
his earthbending buddy who's mastered a
special technique of lava bending in a
metal prison in the middle of a volcano
is a woman with no arms but when they
give her some water oh she's
waterbending arms what a crazy technique
these three breakouts attract the
attention of our boy Fire Lord Zuko he
teams up with kora's Dad to stop Zahir
but Zahir is too much of a badass he
rescues their fire bendor a real tall
girl with oh what's this the combustion
man tattoos yeah Sparky Sparky boom now
unaware of this trouble Brewing team
Avatar has made it to the Grand
Metropolis of bossing unfortunately the
modern has only increased The Divide
between the rich and poor as the new
Earth Queen is a terrible person who
cares more about her shrubberies than
caring for her citizens she tells Kora
there are no Airbenders in bossing SE
which seems unlikely and indeed the dial
are kidnapping them and conscripting
them into an air bender Army team Avatar
won't stand for that and break them all
out which unfortunately makes them
enemies of the earth Kingdom but all
these new air Benders who can't go home
are happy to join the new Air Nation
team Avatar's last stop is the super
cool new metal city of zfu the earth
Benders here have turned metal bending
into a true art form and they're led by
Zu Yin B Fong yes that is tof's other
daughter she and her sister Lynn do not
get along though it's a whole thing
going back to their childhood and
eventually they fight it out and then
make up suan teaches cor metal bending
which she picks up pretty quickly but
Bolin can't pick it up at all but he
does pick up her daughter opal a real
nice girl they hit it off and turns out
she's the new air bender they're here to
recruit but zahir's gang shows up with a
dastardly plot to kidnap the Avatar and
it turns into an epic fight long story
short cor attracts him to the spirit
world where he explains he's a member of
the Red Lotus according to him the White
Lotus has been corrupted they're now
just Pawns of the establishment that
keep people oppressed the Red Lotus is
all about true Freedom which in his mind
is anarchy cor is like you know
governments are bad sometimes in fact
the villains have been corrupt
politicians in every single season so
far but also you go around killing
people so clearly you're the bad guy
there's some more Shenanigans I'm not
going to get into but basically Z here
gets to the Earth Queen and uses his new
air bending powers to oh create a vacuum
and suffocate her and with the Earth
queen dead he incites an anarchist
revolution in bosing then he kidnaps the
new Air Benders but Daddy tends and
ain't messing around oh he shows them
what a real air bendon Master looks like
Zahir captures Kora but he's cornered on
the mountain top but he's been studying
teachings of this ancient air Master
zahir's like all right let's do this
falls off the mountain but oh he can fly
now all right the rest of the gang is
having some lava trouble so Bolin steps
up and oh he figured out lava bending
congrats buddy so Zahir wants to kill
the Avatar by poisoning her with some
metal so she'll go into the Avatar State
and kill her then ending the cycle of
reincarnation only flaw in the plan is
that when she goes into the Avatar State
she's a real strong and busts out of
there so Corin here are flying around
having a big old fight but oh the
Poison's still in her system it's
weakened her zahir's got the upper hand
and he's starting to suffocate her but
wait what's this it's all the new Air
Benders forming a big old tornado to
give K the upper hand and take Zahir
down they get the poison out of Kora and
Zahir is defeated so the day is saved
except the poison took a huge toll on
kora's body she's grievously injured
will she ever be the same so now it's
time for book four balance there's a
three-year time Gap and the Earth
kingdom is still in Anarchy luckily the
new Airbenders are here to save the day
with their updated modern wing suit
uniforms cool but they're not the only
ones keeping peace in the earth Kingdom
on an awesome new metal magnet train the
zfu security forces are here led by
kuira she's bringing order to the chaos
and reuniting the fragmented Earth
Kingdom in fact Bolin is here working
for her as well as veric but the
stability she offers comes with a steep
price he's mostly autonomous provinces
must hand over full central control
directly to kuira the great uniter now
the air to the Earth kingdom is Prince
woo a spoiled brat living it up in
Republic City with Mako as his security
Chief but kir is like hey does anyone
really want this guy to be their King I
think the time of monarchy over I
declare a new Earth Empire what does the
Avatar have to say about this while cor
is missing in action she spent a long
time recovering down at the South Pole
and finally decided to symbolically cut
her hair and travel the world to find
herself she's in a bad way though being
haunted by herself and finally finds our
girl Toof yeah just the tough we
remember from Last Airbender except
super old now hermit living in swamp she
can sense there's a little bit of the
metal poison left in her system and long
story short helps Ka get it out of her
so kua's Army is headed back to zfu to
take it by force if necessary but the
Avatar is here to stop her she fights
Kua one-on-one but K is still not really
on top of her game and kuira absolutely
trashes her around this time Bolin
realizes he's working for the bad guy
and veric comes to the same conclusion
in fact var's been experimenting with
Spirit Vines as a source of energy but
turns out they're way unstable and
explode gu wants veric to weaponize it
for her but he refuses so he's under
arrest but what's this his loyal
assistant Julie abandons him she's like
yeah he treats me like garbage makes me
scrub his feet and stuff luckily veric
and Bolin managed to escape and get back
to Republic City to warn them of a new
super weapon earlier Bolin and opal had
a huge fight and broke up because didn't
realize he was working for the bad guy
so now he's doing whatever it takes to
win her back including going on a secret
mission to rescue her family along with
her grandma the family gets rescued but
the spirit Vine super cannon is complete
Julie helped build it but it keeps
malfunctioning and pretty soon kuir
realizes that Julie was lying to her
she's always been loyal to veric and a
good guy then the bongs bust in have a
big old metal bending fight Toff
unleashes a huge earthquake but they're
outnumbered and have to escape ban
redeemed himself he and opal get back
together and veric and Julia are
reunited but she's like hey mister some
of the stuff I said about you not
appreciating me was real so you better
shape up now the world can't really stop
kuira So the plan is to just let her
have the Earth Kingdom but KU looked at
a map and decided that Republic City
should be part of the earth Empire it's
time to invade now Republic city is not
defenseless they've got a strong modern
Army still led by General iro the only
problem would be the Super Spirit Cannon
but that's stuck on the train tracks
except kiras ditched the train and
mounted the cannon on a ridiculous giant
robot and once again it immediately
wipes out General aro's Fleet it's up to
team Avatar to stop this thing but it is
pretty much invulnerable luckily we've
got two super Geniuses on our team three
if you count asami's dad who's released
from prison they build a hummingbird
robot with lasers that can cut through
platinum and asami's dad has to
sacrifice himself to save the day with
the way inside deam Avatar leaps into
action Kora goes for a rematch with
kuira and does a lot better this time
then Mako hits the spirit Vine Engine
with lightning and blam blows this robot
apart kuira escapes to the spirit Forest
where guess what landed the cannon boom
Point Blank blast Avatar State block and
explosion it unleashes so much Spirit
energy that a new spirit portal opens up
right here in the middle of the city cor
and kavir land in the spirit world where
it's like so you recognize you've become
the bad guy in the situation right and
she's like yeah I kind of realized so
kuira surrenders and the day is saved
when things were looking Bleak veric
proposed to Julie admitting that she's
more than his assistant she's his
partner so the series ends with a big
wedding Kora and Mako do not rekindle
their romance though it's been too much
they're just friends it's actually aami
that cor is talking to at the end it's
like you know what screw the boys let's
go on a girls vacation to the spirit
world and what's this they're holding
hands who it's been apparent their
French has been grown into something
more for a while now so more power to
them and that's where legend of Kora
comes to an end if you like this recap
hit that subscribe button for more of
the best Recaps of TV and
movies